Monsieur.  Thibault bienvenue chez un chats sans
merci Annmarie c'est une histoire longue et
passionnante une très complexe
avec des conséquences internationales tu es
au milieu de cette tempête je dirais que
l'acteur principal de tout ça c'est Edward
Snowden au début peux tu nous dire
encore une fois ce qu'il a fait l'ampleur de ce
qu'il a fait en quittant la NSA
bien qu'Edward Snowden était venu à
Hong Kong en mai 2013 et pendant la
dernière partie de mai, il avait communiqué
avec le journaliste Glenn Greenwald
qui travaillait avec le Guardian et Laura
Poitras, le
réalisateur de documentaires primé aux Oscars, mais personne ne
savait qu'à l'époque et pendant environ
la première semaine de juin 2013,
Glenn Greenwald avait publié des articles dans
The Guardian sur la
surveillance électronique massive du gouvernement américain
espionnant essentiellement les gouvernements sur les
civils autour  le monde, y compris l'
espionnage de civils aux États-Unis, au
Canada, au Royaume-Uni, en Nouvelle-Zélande, en Australie, m.
Snowden avait également révélé l'existence
du groupe des cinq yeux qui est les
États-Unis Canada le Royaume-Uni
Australie Nouvelle-Zélande où ils
travaillaient ensemble pour espionner les gouvernements
et les civils et pendant les neuf
ou huit premiers jours de juin 2013 ces
histoires arrivaient  hors de Hong Kong,
ces histoires ont eu un impact énorme sur
les droits à la vie privée des civils
du monde entier et également sur le gouvernement,
puis le matin du 10 juin à Hong
Kong et qui auraient été déposés dans
la soirée du 9 juin en Amérique du Nord
m.  .  Snowden s'est exposé et j'ai
reçu un appel téléphonique tôt le
matin du 10 juin
et je ne peux pas entrer dans les détails de cet
appel téléphonique mais m.  Snowden avait besoin d'
une aide immédiate et j'avais réalisé
que c'était évidemment l'individu
qui divulguait les activités de la
NSA des États-Unis maintenant qu'il était à
l'hôtel Mira et c'est dans la
matinée du 10 et et vous
n'avez qu'à considérer que  tous les médias
du monde étaient qu'ils
convergeaient littéralement vers l'hôtel,
ils convergent en fait vers un certain nombre d'
hôtels et suivent les médias et et
il ne faisait aucun doute dans mon esprit que ce serait
le gouvernement américain et d'autres gouvernements,
donc votre choix était de trouver  un refuge pour
lui et vous avez choisi de le faire héberger
par d'autres clients à vous car vous êtes un
spécialiste des cas de réfugiés un cas de demandeurs d'
asile que vous êtes bien connu et
votre réputation à Hong Kong était basée
sur cela donc votre choix était de  la trouver
avec un refuge et vous avez demandé à certains de
vos clients réfugiés de l'abriter
pourquoi c'est une situation où littéralement mr.
Snowden a été confié à mes soins en tant que
conseil et il y avait la plus grande
chasse à l'homme de la planète qui venait juste de commencer, le
gouvernement des États-Unis lancerait
la plus grande chasse à l'homme de la planète, il
y avait donc très peu de temps pour réfléchir et
ma principale préoccupation était mon client, M.
Snowden, il aurait été très
difficile d'amener mr.  Snowden à
un autre hôtel ou à Nord quelqu'un qui
réside habituellement à Hong Kong parce
qu'il y aurait des caméras, les gens parleraient
et vous savez, connaissant mes clients depuis de nombreuses
années, la communauté de réfugiés à Hong
Kong, leur seule véritable structure de soutien
est eux-mêmes et ils ont une pratique
et ils avaient l'
habitude d'inviter d'autres
demandeurs d'asile nouvellement arrivés à Hong Kong chez
eux pour les aider, ils ne savaient pas que nous
étions à un moment où j'ai amené m.
Snowden à la première famille et aussi
aux autres familles qu'à différentes
dates ils ne savaient pas qui nous étions
sauf pour l'un des réfugiés de Snowden, l'
un des réfugiés de Snowden savait qui il
était tout de suite et et lui et que
ce client  était plus qu'heureux d'aider
mr.  Snowden parce qu'il a vu m.  Snowden
comme étant, vous savez, dans la même situation
qu'il avait été lorsqu'il a fui la persécution dans
son pays d'origine, mais les clients
n'ont pas vraiment apprécié la gravité
ou mieux mis l'ampleur de cette affaire
en termes de vous connaissez l'intérêt mondial
chaque chaque  pays dans le monde à ce
moment-là était de savoir comment l'intérêt de sécurité
avec mr.  Snowden ce qu'ils ont vu comme ils ont
vu mr.  Snowden comme dans une personne en
détresse qui faisait face à la persécution
et c'est tout ce qu'ils ont vu ils l'ont
reconnu et ils ont voulu l'aider ces
familles ont accepté d'abriter m.  Snowden,
mais à l'époque, en tant que leur avocat des
deux, aviez-vous l'impression que vous
vous mettiez dans une sorte de conflit d'
intérêts et croyiez-vous que vous
étiez en tant que jeune barreau de kong, que
vous les avez mis en danger et les avez mis en danger
parce que c'était  l'homme le plus recherché de
la planète
non, je n'ai pas vu que je mettais l'un de mes
clients dans ce genre de danger m.
Snowden était simplement un demandeur d'asile
et il a été placé et vous savez avec d'
autres personnes qui étaient dans
une situation fondamentalement similaire à celle de m.  Snowden,
mais pas à une aussi grande échelle que mr.
Snowden, le deuxième problème est que mes clients
sont des adultes et mes clients ont reçu
des conseils complets et
ils auraient pu dire non, ils, vous
savez, ils ne veulent pas aider m.  Snowden,
ils ne veulent pas prendre ce risque
et nous leur avions dit très clairement
que si quelqu'un se présentait à la porte à la
recherche de m.  Snowden de ne pas interférer
vous savez et mr.  Snowden a été très clair
ou avec eux aussi il leur a dit regardez
si quelqu'un me cherche ici
je vais sortir j'irai avec eux vous savez que
vous ne devez pas intervenir en mon nom
ils ont été encouragés à l'aider et vous
savez  J'étais reconnaissant pour leur
volonté de fournir un abri, de la nourriture, de l'
empathie et de l'humanité à m.  Snowden pendant
une très courte période, nous sommes en
mesure de refuser, ils étaient en
mesure de refuser s'ils le voulaient,
ils auraient pu refuser à tout moment et
nous leur avons dit très clairement si vous
parlez avec mes clients, ils ont  tous ont
exprimé à plusieurs reprises que c'était leur
décision d'aider m.  Snowden et si on
leur demande s'ils recommencent, ils ont
tous dit qu'ils recommenceraient mr.
monsieur auraient-ils été ciblés pour
avoir abrité Edward Snowden pouvez-vous
nous donner quelques exemples de ces
conséquences qu'ils ont subies
pour faire partie des
familles Snowden ce à quoi nous ne nous attendions pas était que le
gouvernement de Hong Kong cible ces
familles pour les célibataires  pour essayer de
faire accélérer leurs cas non pas dans le
but d'évaluer le bien-fondé de leurs cas
afin que les clients aient été ciblés par le
directeur de l'immigration
ils ont été isolés parmi environ 50 50
clients ou plus à moi le gouvernement
a cessé de fournir un loyer  et
aide humanitaire aux clients
la personne qu'ils ont le plus durement ciblée
et punie était Vanessa Rodell la
mère philippine avec la petite fille
Kiana et la même chose est arrivée à
super Nana dica et leur enfant ils ont eu
un deuxième enfant après 2013 donc c'est une
famille de  quatre, l'aide humanitaire de l'humanité
qui leur a été également
supprimée par le
gouvernement de Hong Kong, c'était donc dans la dernière
partie de 201  6 puis en 2007,
fin 2016, la police sri-lankaise
s'est rendue à Hong Kong en ciblant les
réfugiés enneigés et nous avons été choqués
par cela, mais encore une fois, comme je l'avais dit
plus tôt, Hong Kong a une histoire de
coopération avec les gouvernements étrangers et
la sécurité étrangère  forces donc à deux niveaux,
il y a eu des attaques du gouvernement contre
les réfugiés snowden, l'une était directe en
essayant d'interférer et d'entraver le conseil
dans leurs cas, en supprimant
l'aide humanitaire, puis en troisième lieu,
en engageant une enquête pénale contre
moi-même l'avocat maintenant le barreau de yung kong
essaie de  vous radier pour priver votre
client venice' par exemple d'avoir une
représentation avoir un avocat avoir
un avocat vous n'êtes plus à Hong Kong
vous avez dû partir de Hong Kong vous êtes
Je n'ai pas à vous considérer en
exil mais dans certains  les façons dont vous devez rester à l'
écart de Hong Kong car votre
relation avec Snowden était un nous pouvons toujours
être votre client ce qui dans votre
esprit essaie de faire le bar  le barreau du jeune
kong contre vous mes clients n'ont
jamais déposé de plainte auprès de l'association du barreau
ils n'ont jamais porté
plainte contre vous savez que je leur demande
d'aider mr.  Snowden et l'Association du Barreau
tentent de peindre
une image que je mets mes clients en danger
et il faut considérer qu'en 2013, il
n'était jamais prévu qu'Oliver Stone
ferait un film intitulé Snowden qui
sortirait en septembre 2016
les identités des clients  étaient confidentiels
et ils ne devaient pas être divulgués et
Oliver Stone a sorti le film et mes
clients sont représentés dans le film leurs
identités ne sont pas divulguées leurs
identités spécifiques mais je n'ai qu'un
nombre limité de clients et quand nous avons
découvert cela, nous avons tous  sommes allés voir les
clients et nous avons demandé aux clients ce
que vous aimeriez faire et nous les avons informés
qu'il y avait des risques s'ils restaient
silencieux et continuaient à dissimuler leur
identité et les clients ont exprimé
qu'ils avaient peur que quelqu'un les
trouve vous connaissez l'obscurité de  nuit
quand aucun avocat n'était là et que
quelque chose de mal leur arriverait ou
qu'ils disparaîtraient, l'autre option était
pour eux de s'exposer pour s'assurer
e tout le monde savait qui ils étaient et
Hong Kong est censé être une juridiction sûre,
donc il y avait une
décision prise par eux et eux
seuls qu'ils voulaient parler avec les médias
et faire savoir aux médias publics qui
ils étaient pourquoi Oliver  Stone, faites-
le, pensez-vous qu'il a une responsabilité et
les conséquences qu'ils subissent
maintenant, Oliver Stone a été très
favorable aux clients et quand il a
fait le film, il avait des informations sur
les réfugiés snowden et cela faisait
partie de l'histoire d'Edward Snowden et
c'était quelque chose qui ne venait pas de moi,
cela ne venait de personne ni de
l'équipe juridique, mais la pierre avait découvert
mais a abrité et sauvé mr.  La vie de Snowden
alors parlez-nous des représailles auxquelles
vous faites face de la part du klaxon bien après
la sortie du film Snowden Le film Snowden d'Oliver Stone
et je l'
ignorais jusqu'en mars 2017, le barreau de Hong Kong a
pris sur lui d'
examiner deux plaintes anonymes et
c'est  lié à M.  Snowden, puis en
mars 2017, j'ai reçu une lettre et
c'était une lettre du conseil du barreau
indiquant qu'il y avait une
plainte anonyme contre moi et je n'avais aucune idée de
la forme de la plainte anonyme, de
qui elle provenait
, puis du conseil du barreau  m'a accusé d'
avoir consulté les médias en m'étant
conduit d'une manière où je mettais mes
clients en danger, les revenus de Snowden en
danger et numéro deux, ils se sont plaints que
j'avais fait tout cela pour gagner de l'argent pour
obtenir plus d'affaires, ce qui est ridicule la
plupart du temps  le travail que je fais pour les demandeurs solennels
est un salaire très bas ou pro bono, donc vous vous
battez
pourquoi allez-vous actuellement en public maintenant
en ce jour du 28 novembre, je le fais en
public maintenant parce que l'Association du Barreau de Hong Kong
à travers l'
anonyme  les plaintes motivées par
ces plaintes anonymes ont porté
cinq nouvelles plaintes contre moi
devant le tribunal d'affichage du barreau et c'est
simplement l'association du barreau qui
interfère avec ma capacité à pratiquer le
droit l  terriblement à Hong Kong en particulier
pour les réfugiés enneigés par rapport au fait
que les clients sont émotionnellement et
psychologiquement compromis et que les
clients sont compromis et nous sommes également
conscients que le gouvernement de Hong Kong
va prendre des décisions sur toutes les
demandes d'asile à peu près à cette époque  donc la
combinaison de facteurs mais vraiment ce sont
les actions de l'Association du Barreau pour
interférer avec moi qui m'ont amené à
ce point où j'ai décidé de rendre
public donc toutes ces plaintes et
plaintes Animus vous les
combattez mais vous êtes dans  exilez maintenant donc le
résultat final pour vous qu'est-ce que c'est maintenant
avez-vous encore que vous êtes toujours
l'avocat de venise 'vous devez vous
battre pour vous-même
quel est le résultat final pour vous maintenant à partir de
là est-ce politique de l'ivresse au bar
est  c'est absolument politique à cause de cela
c'est absolument à cause de
Snowden c'est absolument politique c'est
honteux ce que le barreau de Hong Kong
a fait les conseils illégaux
que j'ai reçus  d'un certain nombre de Queen's
Counsel sont qu'il n'y a aucun moyen que je puisse
retourner à Hong Kong et comparaître devant un
tribunal disciplinaire du barreau et bénéficier d'une
audience équitable qui est impossible et
encore une fois je dirai que vous savez que tout
est clairement basé sur  mon association
avec m.  Snowden et le travail que j'ai
fait pour défendre et me battre pour les
réfugiés de Snowden, toutes ces plaintes ont
commencé et se sont accumulées sur moi
après le film d'Oliver Stone pas avant,
alors quel est le résultat le plus prévisible
pour les familles Snowden maintenant à ce
temps bien en 2016 et et
c'est quelque chose qui est perdu sur l'Association du Barreau
il y a un
taux d'acceptation de 2% de réfugiés à Hong Kong
et j'ai réalisé et tout le monde a accepté
cela que c'était presque une certitude que les
cas d'asile de réfugiés enneigés seraient
rejetés à Hong Kong et ils seraient
renvoyés dans leur pays d'origine pour faire face à des
mauvais traitements, à la persécution, alors j'ai
approché un groupe d'avocats basés à Montréal
et je leur ai révélé qui
étaient les réfugiés de Snowden et j'ai dit que
j'aimerais vraiment trouver  une façon de déposer une
demande de statut de réfugié au Canada parce
que c'est vraiment leur meilleure chance
et c'est vraiment la façon de les protéger
parce qu'à Hong Kong avec un
taux d'acceptation de 0,2% t  il n'y a pas de protection
pour les demandeurs d'asile à Hong Kong, donc l'
horloge tourne, il est
minuit moins cinq pour eux, oui l'
horloge tourne, il est minuit moins cinq
et ils sont affligés et
tout ce que je peux dire à ce stade est  est de demander à
m.  Trudeau et demandez au Canada d'agir maintenant,
vous savez que tout retard supplémentaire dans ces
cas n'aidera pas du tout les clients
. Croyez-vous en une procédure équitable et
indépendante d'Immigration
Canada
maintenant, puisque les relations avec les États-
Unis ici sont bien influencées maintenant par
le gouvernement trom mais même le
président Obama à une époque ne
considérait pas Snowden comme un patriote, il a fait
ce qu'il a fait était mal
que le Canada a
une procédure juste et indépendante pour
accepter la scène de la famille Snowden sans
entre m.  Trump hors de son esprit
oh une chose que je devrais mentionner d'emblée
est l'ancien procureur général Eric
Holder après avoir quitté son poste au sein du
gouvernement américain avait déclaré que ce que
Snowden avait fait était d'un service public et
cela fait cinq ans depuis plus de
cinq ans  depuis M.  Les révélations de Snowden
et il y a eu
un changement graduel parmi vous connaissez
des gens très
conservateurs, des opinions très conservatrices que m.  Snowden avait
mis des vies en danger et mais en fait ce n'est
pas ce qui s'est passé et il y a eu un
changement constant de
vision plus favorable de ce que Snowden a fait en 2013 le
deuxième problème est les réfugiés de Snowden et
je veux clarifier cela n'a jamais enfreint aucune
loi par  héberger et aider m.
snowden en 2013 parce que mr.  snowden a
toujours été légalement à hong kong même si
mr.  snowden était considéré comme un fugitif
aux États-Unis en vertu de la loi de Hong Kong
m.  Snowden n'avait enfreint aucune loi et
il n'y avait pas de
demande d'extradition effective envoyée par le cœur du gouvernement américain au
gouvernement de Hong Kong,
donc les réfugiés de Snowden et moi aimerions
vraiment encadrer cela dans un contexte approprié,
ce sont des personnes qui ont subi des
persécutions  et la torture et leurs
pays d'origine,
ils ont fui à Hong Kong pour une
protection qu'ils n'ont vraiment pas reçue, mais
du gouvernement de Hong Kong et leur
humanité extraordinaire les a amenés à prendre
soin de m.  Snowden maintenant, il y a trois
enfants qui sont nés à Hong Kong de
ces familles, ils sont tous apatrides et
ce sont des enfants innocents et ces
enfants sont à un âge et ils
arrivent à un âge où vous savez qu'ils
sont affectés par ce qui se passe  et
nous demandons au Canada d'agir maintenant pour retirer
ces clients de cet environnement à
Hong Kong pour moi, il est impensable que
le gouvernement de Hong Kong renvoie
ces enfants dans leur pays d'origine, le
pays d'origine de leurs parents et
vous savez, je dirais que vous savez
Le Canada devrait réfléchir très attentivement à
ses engagements envers les réfugiés et à
son cadre juridique et à ses
engagements historiques envers les réfugiés parce qu'il s'agit d'
un cas où il s'agit d'une seule étape très simple
pour le Canada d'embrasser ces
familles courageuses et de les faire venir
au Canada et cela devrait  être une
décision qui ne devrait prendre en
compte aucune considération politique
de l'administration Trump, ce sont des
gens qui, juste par des actes o  f gentillesse a
aidé un homme qui a révélé
une conduite criminelle et flagrante du gouvernement des États-
Unis, c'est donc urgent pour eux car
si l'immigration de Hong Kong décide
quelque chose sur leur cas, ils pourraient être
expulsés vers leur propre pays
avant même que le Canada ne prenne une
décision qui est  votre plus grande peur de mourir
par retard si le Canada continue de retarder ces
clients vont être expulsés et
renvoyés dans leur pays d'origine
et sur la base des preuves de ces cas,
certains de ces clients ne
vivront pas et ces familles souffrent dans nos
souffrances  Hong Kong et ces
enfants sont vulnérables et
vous savez que c'est le cas où nous
demandons au Canada s'il vous plaît d'agir et s'il vous plaît agissez
maintenant êtes-vous toujours en contact avec m.
Snowden et qu'attend-il maintenant
pour 20/20 car il est en Russie jusqu'en
2020 oui je suis en contact avec mr.  Snowden
et d'après ma compréhension de toutes les
preuves et qu'en 2020, m.  Le
visa actuel de Snowden expirera et il
demandera un autre visa et, comme le gouvernement russe l'
a déclaré publiquement à plusieurs
reprises auparavant, il n'y a aucune raison pour
qu'il ne donne pas à m.  Snowden un autre
visa il n'a enfreint aucune loi en Russie
vous pratiquez un droit de saloon ou
à Hong Kong depuis tant d'années vous êtes
dévoué à vos clients vous l'avez toujours
été c'est votre réputation vous semblez
très bien dévoué au snowden
familles et veulent se battre pour leur
liberté leur sécurité maintenant es-tu plus
que leur avocat pour eux es-tu un
militant ou un activiste pour eux pour la
pour leur liberté diriez-vous que cette
partie de l'ADN d'un avocat réfugié je
pense que c'est  cela fait partie de l'ADN d'
un avocat spécialisé dans les réfugiés et avec le
taux d'acceptation de 0,2% à Hong Kong en
tant qu'avocat, je reconnais que les chances
de réussir sont si minces, mais que
réussir ou avoir une chance de réussir
nécessite un effort énorme et un
engagement à long terme et vous savez qu'il
y a là vous connaissez quelques avocats que vous
connaissez dans ce domaine de pratique et vous savez que
les avocats qui ont du succès sont très
engagés envers leurs clients mais maintenant vous
êtes condamné à vivre en exil  e oui je le suis
et non cela n'a rien à voir avec ce
que j'ai fait j'ai fait mon travail je l'ai fait
légalement et je l'ai fait avec beaucoup d'
engagement et d'attention envers mes clients
la raison pour laquelle je suis  l'exil maintenant est à
cause du gouvernement de Hong Kong et à
cause de leurs actions et et je
dirais que ce qu'ils ont fait est un
exemple de faiblesse humaine que le
gouvernement de Hong Kong a ciblé les plus
vulnérables et ciblé un avocat qui se
bat pour le plus  vulnérable en tant
qu'avocat, je parle pour ceux qui ne peuvent pas
parler pour eux-mêmes et je pense qu'il est
honteux que le
gouvernement de Hong Kong ait fait ce qu'il a fait
merci beaucoup de rien